- [Ishit] Good morning.
- [Audience] Good morning.
- Well that's great. I love this crowd.
(audience chuckles)
Well, welcome to re:Invent and Las Vegas.
I'm excited to be here with you today.
This is my 13th re:Invent.
I attended first six like
many of you in this room
as a customer of AWS,
and this is my seventh one
as a builder here at AWS.
Now in my role at AWS, I wear dual hat.
I get to lead and build
and solve business problem
using technology and AI.
And I also get to work
with C-Suite and executives
of some of our largest
customers like yourselves.
How many of you in the room
are first time at re:Invent,
show of hand?
Well, wow, many. Welcome.
Any veterans here? Five plus years?
Excellent.
Well, I hope you have a
fantastic week because it's an
amazing time to be a senior
leader in the organization.
What a privilege that we
all have to become the agent
of change and lead our organizations
beyond just automation to high agency.
So in this session over
next 40 minutes or so,
I'm going to talk about
what do leaders need to do
to lead in this new era of high agency?
What are the mental model shifts
that we require as leadership team?
How do we re-envision
our business processes
and then go slightly deeper
into some of the technical
and architectural capability
that help bring this vision to life.
So let's dive in.
Now, I'm sure many of you
have seen lot of things being
labeled as agents,
but when you peel back that wrapper,
underneath that you find
many of these things.
You have just good old scripted automation
that takes repetitive predictable task
and in a fixed set of workflows, codes it.
As you move up that autonomy chain,
you have generative AI assistance
and the chat bots that
provide useful information,
has access to data,
can respond to queries,
can actually summarize the
document and information
and has an ability to respond,
but very limited ability to act.
As you move up that autonomy chain,
we start to see higher order business task
and the goal that these agents can do.
The goal and task-based
agents are optimized
for completing a specific
task by working with humans.
This is where we start
to see lot higher value.
And then at pretty high up is
the highest level of autonomy
of agentic system where
multiple agents work together,
take a much higher order complex
and sometimes ambiguous task
and are able to break that down
into steps and pursue that.
So this is a good mental model
to think about when your teams come
and talk to you about
automation or AI agents.
Now this is not to say that
one is better than the other.
As senior leaders, it is
important that we understand
what tool to apply to solve which problem.
So the question that I really
find useful when I'm talking
to my team is to what are the behaviors
or attributes that makes
something an agentic system?
So let's talk about what
are some of those behaviors.
Agentic systems are goal driven.
As I talked about, they
take a higher order goal
or an intent and have an
ability to break that into
multiple chunk- chunks of
tasks to go and complete.
They are resourceful, they have an ability
to access the tools, the data,
the context, the hierarchy
and the roles inside of your organization
to take those action.
They remember, they have a memory,
so that you don't start again
when you have a new transaction.
They remember that there was an issue
with the billing last time
I tried to do something.
They learn and adapt.
They get better with the feedback
and they use escalation not just
as a mechanism when something is wrong,
but as an inbuilt trust mechanism
to involve human in the loop.
So it's good to keep this framing in mind
when you think about agentic system.
Now you might ask, but
we've been on this journey
for a couple of years now, so why now?
What has changed?
And there are two fundamental shifts
that are happening very, very rapidly
that we as senior leaders
need to pay attention to.
The first thing that is happening
is that the unit of task
or the length of task
that AI can do is doubling
roughly every seven months or so.
So you now can take a
lot more complex tasks
and give agents to go and
accomplish those tasks.
Now as senior leaders, we know
that just having a technology
or tool that is very
intelligent and highly capable
but is extremely
expensive and unaffordable
is not very useful, is it?
So what is also happening on the other end
is that the unit price
or the cost to access
this intelligence is
continuously dropping as well.
MMLU is a standard benchmark,
massive multi-language understand-
massive multi-language task understanding
and that is used to
benchmark language models.
And just to give you the context,
an MMLU of 43 is similar to
a struggling high schooler.
They mostly are guessing answers,
but they're very confident.
I have one at home so I
know how that feels like,
I'm sure many of you do too.
But MMLU of 83 is like a PhD level expert.
They understand the nuance,
they are able to deal with ambiguity.
And so we can see that
MMLU and the unit price
to access both of this is dropping.
So we are in this sweet where
the capability are increasing
and the unit price and
the cost is dropping.
And this is why we are starting
to see real world applications of agents.
Druva is a data security company
I'm sure many of you
in this room use them.
Now when you're dealing with
a cybersecurity incident,
a ransomware attack, you
don't have time to go
through like thousands of pieces of logs
and information manually
to sift through that
when you're in middle of the crisis.
And so Druva worked with
AWS to build Dru AI.
These are agents that don't just respond,
but they take action.
They look at proactively the logs
and autonomously detect the system issues
and then they take corrective action,
they move the data around,
they update the policies,
they move the data through
a storage that is lot more
cost effective based on
the data retention in the
policies that you set,
driving lot higher value.
But to take advantage of this requires
a change in how we lead.
If you think about historically,
leadership has been mainly about
optimizing for determinism.
We are all rewarded for lowering
and reducing deviation, having repeatable,
predictable processes that
do the same thing over
and over again by reducing the error rate.
And now this works today.
But the non-determinism,
the ability to improvise,
the ability to adapt, the
ability to take different action
based on the context
and changing requirement
with agent is a feature, not a bug.
Now I'm sure this might
make some of us nervous,
especially from regulated industries.
So this is not about just
stepping into the wild west.
This is about us as leaders being aware
that the non-determinism is
what gives agents the power
and how do we safely harness this
by setting up the right guardrails.
And the mental model that I
find useful is to think about
how we work with some of
our high agency teammates.
You don't call your high
agency teammate every Monday
and say, hey, I'm going
to sit down with you
to give you specific
tasks that you are going
to execute every single day
and then you're going to come
and at the end of the day,
report to me what you did.
Right? We actually give them a strategic
higher order intent, we
give them the boundaries
within which they can operate,
we empower them with the right resources
and access that they
need to get the job done,
and then we trust them to escalate to us
and involve us as needed.
And so to lead in this
high agency requires
a shift in the leadership model
because we are no longer
managing automation,
we are managing thousands
of agents at scale.
And that intelligent autonomy
and managing that at scale
requires shift into four key
areas of leadership.
Now, please keep in mind
that the mental model
that I'm going to share
are just mental models.
They are not recipes or
strict operating model.
So take them with that lens
and four areas that I'm
going to cover starting
with governance.
Now traditionally,
whether it is in software
or in compliance, we have
gate based governance
system moves, comes to a
complete stop, waits for someone
to verify a series of
things via a checklist
that has been defined
and maybe audited a
couple of times a year.
They approve it, then
the system moves again,
stops again at the next toll gate.
Now this works today, but
when you have hundreds
and thousands of agents,
you can't put these toll booths in front
of them consistently.
That will just slow it down.
Instead, the mental model that is useful
is to think about providing
that strategic intent
and then having a policy engine
that can govern this at scale.
And as I was thinking about,
well, what governs like this?
The, the thing that came to
my mind is that if you look at
how board of directors
actually work with the CEO.
Once again, they don't go to CEO
and say, I'm going to tell you exactly how
to run your company every single day.
Board and CEO typically align on
a strategic direction and the vision,
periodically they go
and audit and calibrate.
But there is also
specific guardrails around
what requires board approval
and the management team knows
when to engage the board.
So it's a useful mental model
to think about governance this way.
The second shift is in risk.
Now today, our risk management
controls are pretty much
like a factory floor.
On a factory floor you have
fixed threshold, right?
Even today in many of our organizations,
we have fixed threshold regardless
of the exposure of the risk.
So if a purchase order
is more than $2 million,
it requires approval of a vice president.
If it is beyond $10 million,
it must go to the CFO.
Now these controls for risk
break down when you're dealing
with autonomy at scale.
The mental model that I find
useful is to think about
managing the risk like a trading floor.
And on our trading floor,
the risk is actually managed
lot more aggressively,
but it is managed through real
time visibility and control.
Traders have a portfolio that
they can play the trades in.
Not every move is managed,
but if the portfolio
or a particular transaction
violates the policy,
then there are circuit breakers
that stops the trading.
Let's say the portfolio drops by 20%,
the circuit breaker kicks
in and stops the trading.
And so we need to think
about agents this way
where agents have to earn their liquidity
by operating within the risk controls
and the boundaries that we design
and have it with real time
visibility and automation.
And it's also not about
managing every single agentic
transaction, but also
monitoring the systematic drift
in a multi-agent system.
When that happens, you want the
circuit breakers to kick in.
One of the most fundamental
change though is going
to be in the organization structure.
And again, as leaders, we all know this.
Every single time there has been a major
technological change, that
has required us to reimagine
and rethink how we organize.
Before cloud, we had application
and development teams
and then infrastructure and
technology operation team.
When cloud came, these
boundaries got blurred.
You started to get full
stack engineering teams
that can operate at all
layers of the stack.
In fact, with agents, we
are seeing this inside
of our own teams where boundaries
beyond just engineering,
including the business process
roles, product management,
engineering, TPMs are all getting blurred
because you have an ability to execute
and work with agents throughout
the entire value chain.
Historically, our org structures
are vertically optimized.
Now this structure provides a stability,
but it is not designed to move fast.
If a customer has an
issue that gets handed off
sequentially between the
department from customer support
to supply chain to distribution
to return and refund
and it slows it down.
But the mental model to use in
terms of how do you organize
for agents is like an immune system.
How does our body's immune system work?
If there is a threat or
if there is a problem
our white blood cells don't wait
for a memo from the brain, right?
They don't call a meeting with the lungs,
they actually swarm that problem
and then figure out how to solve that.
So the cross-functional
teams that are organized
around a business workflow, regardless
of the current departmental structure
is how you really get outcome from agents.
The other thing that happens in this kind
of art structure is that
system learns constantly.
So it's sort of like
creating antibodies, right?
So when you have this responsive swarm,
it gets better with period of time.
The last piece,
and so before, before I go
there, really what we need
to think about is that
agents should not be limited
by your org chart.
They should be limited by the
objective that they're pursuing.
That brings us to the last part
of this leadership mental model
and that is around culture.
Historically, we have all optimized the
culture for precision.
It's sort of like, well,
you gotta almost hit a
bullseye every single time.
That's what we reward,
a perfect execution.
But what happens in a
research lab like culture,
that culture is open to new discovery,
sometimes good, sometimes bad.
But if those mistakes happen,
they are used as a learning mechanism.
They're documented,
they are shared widely,
and the new discovery and
adaptation is once again
a feature, not a bug in
this kind of a culture.
And so that's the shift that we need
because what we are trying
to scale is not obedience.
We are actually trying
to scale the intelligence
throughout our organization.
And so the four key
leadership mental model shifts
that I talked about, governance
like board of directors,
that provides strategic direction,
the continuous calibration
and the guardrail
risk management like a trading floor
where you have real time
visibility and circuit breakers.
And then agents earn their liquidity
and authority to operate
by consistently showing us
that they're operating
within those risk controls.
The organization structure
that is like an immune system
that is a lot more fluid and responsive.
And then finally, the culture
that is like a research
lab culture that is open
to new discoveries.
If you wanna read more,
you can scan that QR code
and dive deeper into some
of these mental models.
Now I wanna talk about
the business process
and I'm going to pick a business process
that I'm pretty sure
most of us in this room
are familiar with, which
is accounts payable.
Now traditionally the goal
of an accounts payable
business process has been to pay invoices
on time and accurately.
And I want all of us to time
travel to pre-ERP days, right?
So just stay with me here.
In the pre-ERP days,
what happened was that
an account payable system
had a fixed goal to pay
every invoice on time and accurately,
but the workflows were vertical.
So procurement will process the PO,
receiving will confirm
the receipt of the goods,
treasury will make the payment,
and AP will post the invoice and so on.
The SOPs were all
vertically inside of each
of the department and the function
and then there was sequential
handoff that happened.
Now in this kind of a system,
if there was any error
or an issue, it'll manually
get kicked back into
the previous process.
Somebody will have to call the
department to fix that issue.
How many of you in the room have been part
of an ERP implementation or run an ERP?
Okay, several of you.
Now, what happened during ERP is
that we could not look at
these vertical processes.
We had to re-engineer an
AP process horizontally.
We had to connect the dots
between procurement, receiving,
treasury, AP and so on.
That- that forced us to talk
across department and function
to relay out our business process.
But that- there was still limitation
because the goal was
still fixed, which was
to pay the invoices on
time and accurately.
And if there was an issue,
anytime during the process
it'll get kicked back and
then manually you'll have to
handle the exception.
Now, what if in an agentic
system that I described earlier,
we take a lot higher magnitude goal.
What if the goal of AP is not
just to pay invoice on time
but to optimize our cash flow?
And the system has the
freedom to operate fluidly
within the boundaries that we set.
So a particular invoice will
go through all of the steps,
but then a second invoice comes in
and the agents will know
that this invoice is in Euro
and I have a 60 day payment
term on this particular invoice.
That means I'm going to
call a Forex trading agent
and say, can I invest this for 59 days
and actually improve my cash flow?
Or a third invoice comes
in and it recognizes
that last four times I
approved this particular
vendor payment, it had to go into dispute
because we did not like the quality
of the deliverable that the vendor had.
And so this time, I'm going to proactively
bring human in the loop and say,
even though approval
processes have confirmed,
I'm going to enroll the human and say,
hey, last four times we didn't
like what happened here.
Do you still want me to pay?
And so that's a lot higher order task,
but also a lot more fluid workflows
that are happening here.
Today, though as I was talking about,
we are already seeing
goal-based agents being in play.
This is where you have a planning agent
or a planner that takes
this higher order task,
breaks it into manageable chunk,
and then you have orchestrator
that works across individual
agents inside of each of the
function like procurement,
receiving, AP, treasury and
goods to get to the payment
and reduce the cycle time.
In fact, we are seeing
this in Amazon as well.
I'll give you an example of
an orchestrator within Amazon.
In our warehouses, we
have over a million robots
that actually help us safely
and quickly move the packages around.
And we have this orchestrator
called deep fleet
sort of think about this as
a brain of this robotic fleet
that manages these 1
million robots distributed
all over the world, across our warehouses.
And by constantly optimizing that,
we are able to reduce
the travel time by 10%.
Now, 10% may not sound a lot,
but at our scale with million robots
and multiple hundreds,
hundreds of warehouses
and distribution center,
that means that we are able
to get the packages faster to you.
And so that's an example
of an orchestrator operating at scale,
optimizing the business outcome.
Now, earlier I talked about the behaviors
of an agentic system.
Let's double click.
We talked about the behaviors,
we talked about the
leadership mental model,
as well as the business process changes.
Let's double click and say
what are the technical capabilities
that bring these behaviors to life?
And there are three
things that agents need.
And again, if you wanna
geek out a little bit more
in architectural implication,
you can scan this QR code
and read an article
that dives a lot deeper
into the architectural
implication in your environment.
But really, agents need three things.
They need intelligence, they need context,
and they need trust.
And, and if we were to think
of agent as sort of human body,
here is how that looks like.
The intelligence is sort of like the brain
of the agentic system.
And your models including
your thinking models
for chain of thought,
reasoning, reflection,
they provide the brain an
ability to take the intent
and break it into task.
But just having a brain is
sort of like having a brain
in a jar, right?
It cannot take any action.
So you then have the access, the context,
which provides agent and ability
to access the right data.
It provides an ability
to actually take action.
to access the tools to go
and make things happen.
And that's sort of like having the hands
to go and do the work.
But without trust, none of this matters.
And so the final layer
of this is the trust.
It is sort of like having an ID badge.
What is the agent's identity?
Who are they operating on behalf?
What are their authorizations
to execute and do this task?
And then what are the guardrails
that they are going to operate within,
to make sure that they're
doing this safely?
And so let's double
click on each one of them
and say, what are some of
the implication in terms
of technical choices that we have to make?
So the first thing is that
agents need intelligence.
Now in a, in an ideal world, we would want
the most intelligent agent
at the lowest possible price
at the fastest possible speed
that we want to optimize
on all three of them.
But in real life, based on your use case,
based on the problem that
you're trying to solve,
you might not need all three
of these in equal measure.
In fact, there is a trade off.
So if you're working with an
agent that is legal agent,
you might say, hey, you know what?
I cannot compromise on
accuracy and intelligence here,
but I'm okay if it takes
half a day or few more hours
or even a day to gimme the response.
So I'm going to optimize for intelligence,
but I'm okay to trade
off on speed of response.
On the other hand, if you're dealing
with a customer service
agent, you want fast,
quick responses because your
customers are not going to
wait for 10 minutes for agent to come back
with a hundred percent accurate answer.
And so this is where
you optimize for speed,
but then you can trade off
on intelligence or the cost.
And this is why when we are thinking
of enabling the intelligence
in the agentic system,
the choice of models, having
access to different types
of model is very important
because every model has
a different strength.
Some models are good with reasoning,
others are very good with quick responses.
Some do text-based task really well,
others do images and
mathematical task really well.
And so this is why our
approach with Amazon Bedrock
has been to make the broadest
and the widest set of models available,
including open source model,
Amazon's own model with Nova,
as well as a lot of third party models.
And we see this application
inside of Amazon businesses
across our company.
Take example of pharmacy.
Now at Amazon Pharmacy, our
goal is to reduce the time
it takes to fill your prescription
and do that accurately.
And sometimes the prescriptions
are handwritten notes.
And this is where we use models
and intelligence to reduce the time
by 90% while reducing
the error rate by 50%.
On the other hand, on Amazon ad site,
we wanna provide the
ability for brands who want
to advertise to take an
image of their product
and actually touch it
up and make it better
and make it a lot more
compelling when they list it.
And this is where we optimize for ability
to generate compelling images.
On the prime video side,
any, any football fans in the house?
All right, some of you?
If, if you're like me,
you always join the game
a little bit late and then
you're like, what did I miss?
And so you have the
feature of rapid recap,
which is where model is going and saying,
here are the key things
or key plays that happen
and let me catch you up as you comment.
Or next gen stats, which actually provides
lot more probability and
information to the viewer,
bringing them closer to the action.
All of these use cases
require different behaviors
and different models.
Take example of our customer, Syngenta.
Now farming, if you think about it, is a,
is one of the most complex
multi-variate problem, right?
A farmer has to take into
account so many different things.
What is the weather
condition? What seed to plant?
When do I plant it? What pesticide to use?
How much should I spray?
Do I fertilize or not?
When do I fertilize it?
Now these are just the factors
that are in their control,
but they're all dependent on
so many other external factors.
The soil condition, the
moisture, the weather pattern,
the pest activity in that particular area.
And this is why Syngenta work with AWS
to develop Cropwise AI, a series of agents
that take information from
multiple different data sources
including soil condition,
historical yield,
the seed quality, but also
80,000 different growth stages
of crop to provide specific
action plan to farmers
on what they need to do when.
Including here's the
prediction of what might happen
next week and this is what
you should be doing right now,
increasing the yield 5%.
Now again, that is sustainable,
but it is also providing
a direct business outcome,
making it easier for the farmers.
So we talked about intelligence,
but as I said, just having
intelligence is sort
of like having a brain
but not an ability to add.
So let's talk about context.
Now, context is sometimes misunderstood
as this is all about just data.
But as I'll show you,
context is lot more than just
your existing data.
In fact, there's a tongue
in cheek statement,
and by the way, this is tongue in cheek,
so take it with that,
from a senior scientist at
Amazon that talks about the fact
that like if you think about this,
anything out of an LLM is a hallucination.
It is our job because
it's basically predicting
the next token and the world.
But it is our job to
provide it the right context
to make sure that that
hallucination is relevant to
what we are trying to solve for.
And this is why there
is a growing importance
of context engineering.
When we think about just
optimizing the prompt,
you're just providing a
one-time input with text.
Now sometimes you give one
shot, you give multiple example,
but it is still back and forth.
With context in your organization,
especially when you're
targeting complex workflow,
you need agents to understand
the role, the hierarchy,
the data, the system, the tools.
And this is why we are seeing emergence
of context engineering
roles in this competency
in many of the organizations.
So to provide this context,
let's talk about what are some
of the technical
capabilities that you need.
The first thing is that
agents need to understand
the relationships in your data.
And take example of a
relationship looks like, right?
Gartner evaluates magic quadrant
and magic quadrant evaluates
technology vendors, right?
That's the relationship
between different objects
and domain inside of your data.
If you're a retailer, if
you're a media company,
if you are a bank, you have many objects,
whether it is customer,
transaction, their trade,
their viewership behavior, where you need
to establish this relationship
so that agents understand
how to navigate your workflows.
And this is why knowledge graph
becomes important in your data strategy.
The second thing that agents
need is that they need
to understand semantics,
which is the adjacency.
Because especially around adaptation
and understanding the ambiguity,
you're not always going
to have an exit term that
an agent is going to go
and search and look for.
This is why they need to
understand what is closer
to what other thing.
So in this example, if we were
to envision this in a
three dimensional space,
cat and dogs both are pets, so
they're closer to each other.
And Gartner magic quadrant
and the leading cloud
providers are sort of far away
from cats and dog.
But if you actually go
into second dimension,
cats and dog are not the same family
and so they are farther apart
and the Gartner Magic
Quadrant is a lot closer
to the leading cloud provider.
And this is why the semantic
understanding of your data
is what AI and agents need.
And this is where vector
databases come into play.
Because vector is the
language that agents speak,
it provides that you need to
provide them relationship,
you need to provide them the semantics.
But all of this won't matter
if you don't have the memory.
And when it comes to
memory, I wanna focus on
the bottom right, the four
things on the bottom right.
Think about priming.
Now, priming is sort of like a mindset.
It's giving a role to your agent
that you are a financial service agent.
That means you're staying in character,
you understand what the
role you are playing.
You then have procedural
memory which provides
the agent the how, right?
This is our email system, this is our ERP.
And so they have the ability
to remember who I am,
what I'm allowed to do and where it is.
Then you have Symantec.
Symantec is sort of like
your world knowledge.
So the memory needs to
understand not just all
of the knowledge that is
available in the world,
but also understand here
is my Q3 sales strategy
and then finally the
episodic memory so that
agents remember what happened last time.
So hey, you know, this particular invoice,
as I shared in the AP example,
had issues four times in previous run.
So I better remember to
address this next time
when I'm encountering this problem.
Because if you don't
provide memory to the agent,
it is sort of like
having a goldfish, right?
It forgets everything and then
you don't get the outcome.
And that creates not only
poor customer experience,
it also destroys some of those behaviors
that I talked about earlier
that it needs to get better,
it needs to remember,
it needs to constantly
optimize and improve.
So we talked about in the
context the relationship
and knowledge graph, semantics,
the vector databases,
four different types of
memory that the agent needs.
But a lot of us know,
especially in large enterprises,
that a lot of our content
is not even in databases,
it is actually in documents
that look like this, right?
And they are designed
typically for all of us
as humans to understand.
We know when we look at this memo to say
it is a large bolded test-
text that looks like a title,
there are section with
numbering and the bullets,
that means I'm looking at a list,
there's a paragraph and a break.
We know how to read
this, but agents don't.
And this is where we need to
focus on taking the content
that is in a lot of these documents
and convert that into .md
machine readable files
that are friendlier to agent.
Here's a wonderful example from Stripe
and you can read more about it in terms of
what they have published,
but which is taking our SOPs,
our documents, our workflows,
our org charts, and making
into machine readable agent
friendly documentation.
Because it's the combination
of structured data, memory,
as well as content which is
going to give the ability
for agents to have this context.
And then the final piece
of this context is ability
to access the tools and
actually take action.
Now before MCP model context
protocol, those of you
who have dealt with lot of APIs know this,
that every time when you don't
have a standard protocol,
you're trying to connect to a system,
you're building a point
to point integration
and that is very, very difficult to scale.
What MCP has done is it's
sort of like a USC port
for giving agent an ability
to access a lot of your tools.
And it allows you to
have a standard interface
across your systems,
your tools, your data,
so that agents have the context
and an ability to access
the tool and the
information that they need.
So the combination of these pieces,
the relationship, semantics,
memory, better content
and MCP or any other
protocol that actually allows
it to access to the tool,
allows us to move from data
just being an asset, which we
have heard many, many times
to actually having
knowledge as a capability.
Because when we are leading
in intelligent autonomy,
we need an ability for
humans and agent to share
the knowledge and be
able to share back that
with each other as well.
And we see this that when
you provide the context,
the outcomes are amazing.
Rufus is Amazon's shopping assistant
and it provides personalized
contextual advice.
So if you're, you know, buying something
and say, does it need AAA
battery or AA battery,
or hey, I bought this
other thing in the past,
does it actually work with the product
that I've already bought?
This year alone, over 250
million shoppers have used Rufus
throughout the year, and
those who use Rufus are
60% more likely to complete a purchase.
And that happens because Rufus understands
and maintains the context and provides
the useful information to the customer.
The last piece is the trust.
Because an intelligent
agent that has an ability
and the context, but the
one that we cannot trust
will never scale in an enterprise.
And one way we can be
sure about the trust is
by setting guardrails.
And as part of Amazon Bedrock, we have m-
we have Amazon Bedrock
guardrails, which allow you
to set specific guardrails
depending on the industry,
your company policy.
For example, before I joined AWS was a CTO
for a global media and
entertainment company.
And that meant that we
could not use certain term
during prime time in our show.
Now imagine having to apply this rule
agent by agent throughout the enterprise.
Well, that will not scale, right?
But Amazon Bedrock Guardrail allows you
to mention the denied topics to say,
hey, never provide financial advice,
do not mention competitor.
And then that applies to
every agentic workflow
and every model that
you're using from Bedrock.
So you can be confident
that these guardrails
are consistently applied.
Think about the sensitive
information filter, the PII,
you don't want that to be exposed.
You can define some of those
rules in the guardrails.
Contextual grounding checks,
which provides information
to all of your agents
that are at a policy level
to say, you know what?
Our return policy is 90 days.
You define it here and every time
there's an interaction it can.
And if there's a conflict,
guardrail will make sure that
that is grounded in the
policy that you defined there.
But one particular area that
I wanna highlight in the trust
is automated reasoning checks.
Now, automated reasoning
checks is a search
for a mathematical proof
that a function, a program,
an agent did something
that it was supposed to do.
Now you're doing this mathematically,
and I'll give you an example
of how this actually works.
So let's say we want to say,
how do we know that
Pythagorean Theorem is correct?
Well, one way to do this is
to try and draw every symbol-
every single variation
of a triangle and then go
and manually measure
everything to make sure
that the theorem is correct.
But that is not practical, right?
That is not how we can prove
the Pythagorean Theorem.
The way we actually establish that
is by having a mathematical
proof that this is correct
without having to manually go and draw
and measure every single
variation of a triangle.
That is exactly how
automated reasoning works.
And as part of Amazon Bedrock guardrail,
automated reasoning checks are available
that reduce the hallucination by over 99%.
And even before agentic AI,
we've been using automated reasoning
for provable security across
AWS for a number of years.
So S3's public storage and blocking that
or VPC access analyzer where you can say,
hey, does my database
have access to internet?
Well, how do you actually
prove that mathematically so
that you have approvable security?
We do this through
Automated Reasoning Check.
And that's one of those
tools that allow us to trust
the agent and make sure
that we are able to
effectively scale them in our companies.
I'll share an example from
Amazon Tax and Compliance.
Now, when you're dealing with tax rules
and compliance all over the world,
you have different policies,
different documents,
and again, it's very
difficult to do this manually.
And so our tax and compliance
team worked with agents
to look at 600 different
companies around the world,
including the tax policies and the rules
to do the benchmarking.
Now that's an example where
the trust is very important
and you have the provable
security to establish that trust.
Now after looking at all
of this, when you start
to move agents and operate
multiple agents in production,
it is still hard.
It requires you to have
better runtime so that you can
isolate each of the
runtime, as I talked about,
it needs memory so that it
remembers different types
of memory that I mentioned earlier.
You need to provide an
identity to that agent so
that you know who's
that acting on behalf of
and what it is allowed to do.
It needs access to different
tools, it needs gateway
that it can access information from,
and then it needs observability
so that you can validate
and audit and feel
confident that it is doing
what you want it to do.
Now all of this requires a set
of solid primitives.
And if you as senior
leaders, if you go back
to like just basic
components of primitives
or the building blocks, if you had compute
and storage, we pretty much can build
many different application.
You can create a website,
you can create an ERP,
you can create a CRM with
just compute and storage.
We believe that inference is going
to become another building block of all
of the applications that
are going to come out.
And this is why with AgentCore
and Amazon Bedrock, we
provide these building blocks
and perimeters so that all of the things
that I talked about
from identity to memory
to providing access to
the tool across any model,
across any protocol, not just models
that are on Bedrock, AgentCore
allows you to do that.
So that you can provide agent memory,
you can manage the agent identity,
you can provide a runtime
that you know is secure and is isolated,
you can provide the gateway
that manages the connection
with the other tools.
And this is why we are
pretty excited about
what we can build using these primitives.
Now, one of the questions
we often get from leaders is
what are some good places to get started?
Now, as I talked about earlier,
while this is not automation,
it is also not full autonomy.
It- they are still early days.
And so let's keep in mind that
these are still early days
and we make sure that we don't think
of agents as a magic wand.
In fact, if you have
a predictable workflow
with fixed steps, very limited tool use,
then just basic automation,
some gen AI assistant works.
Agents are really good when you
want dynamic tool selection,
when you want to take
advantage of that adaptability
and learning where you want
to do pattern recognition
and matching, where you are
looking at things like latency
and the cost implication
based on the business problem
that you're trying to solve.
And the three specific areas
where we see the biggest value
is in software development,
customer support
and customer care and the
knowledge work, especially when
you're handling exception
loop type processes.
Now, how many of you
in the room do not have
any technical debt?
(audience laughing)
Well, that was a trick question.
Pretty much all of us have technical debt,
and that's a wonderful example
where agents can actually
help us move fast.
Because paying off technical
debt locks in a lot
of our engineering resources
into doing something
that must be done, but doesn't
always necessarily give
better business outcome or features.
It is sort of like managing the risk.
And here's an example
from Thomson Reuters.
They had a lot of .net
legacy code that they had
to modernize and they use AWS transform,
which is our agentic AI
based modernization agent.
And they were able to reduce
and move that modernization 4x faster.
That meant that their
product and engineering teams
can actually solve the business
problems rather than just
paying off the debt.
And so this is a wonderful
example where agents are already
helping us drive better outcomes.
So I would look at your businesses
and find areas like that
where you can start to apply the agent.
Now, none of this matters
if we don't prepare our
organizations with skill and training.
And this is why over last 25 years,
we have invested heavily into the training
and certification.
To build the competency
across not only the companies,
but around the countries,
across the world,
so that we have the
right talent as leaders
to take advantage of this.
A lot of this training
is available for free,
so I encourage not only all of you,
but also encourage your teams
to take advantage of it.
One of my favorite things
here is the AWS AI League.
What I've found leading
product and engineering teams
for a long time is that
gamification is always
a great way to get people highly engaged.
It's a low friction way,
you're making it fun,
people get to learn something.
And that's what AWS AI League does.
Where you can actually host
a competitive fun league
inside of your own company.
We also, I believe, announced
yesterday that there's going
to be a championship
league with $50,000 price
where teams can compete into.
And finally, you're going to need experts
and we are here to help.
There is guidance from AWS experts,
many of the folks from our
executive and residence team
and other experts throughout the company.
We have made over a hundred
million dollar investment
in AWS generative AI Innovation Center
where we bring machine
learning and AI experts from
all over the company to work
alongside you to help you
solve a business problem.
And then AWS marketplace where
you can quickly get access
to some of the prebuilt agents
and tools that you can start
to deploy today in your organization.
It is really a fascinating
and fantastic future
that is ahead of you, and
I'm really excited to see
what you all build together.
I hope you have a fantastic
re:Invent and rest of the week.
Thank you so much.
(audience applause)